en esta ocasión les voy a hablar sobre
el concepto de la transformada de la
plaza que encontrarán es un concepto de
los más útiles que van a aprender no
sólo para ecuaciones diferenciales sino
en general para las matemáticas sobre
todo si ustedes se van a dedicar a la
ingeniería van a encontrar que la
transformada de la plaza es muy útil
además de ser usada para las ecuaciones
diferenciales ustedes la pueden aplicar
para mover o transformar funciones del
dominio del tiempo al dominio de la
frecuencia además de que nos sirve para
comprender y estudiar todo un conjunto
de fenómenos pero eso no lo vamos a ver
ahorita eso lo veremos más adelante
primero vamos a comprender de qué se
trata familiarizarnos con su
terminología y después vamos a ver cómo
la podemos usar para resolver ecuaciones
diferenciales y vamos a comenzar con
ejercicios sencillos y vamos a seguir
haciéndolos un poquito más difíciles
conforme avancemos para que podamos
resolver cosas más complicadas bueno y
qué es la transformada de la plaza
vamos a ver su notación primero está
transformada se va a escribir con una
ele manuscrita un poquito gary goleada y
vamos a abrir una llave y aquí dentro
vamos a escribir la función a la que
queremos aplicar en la transformada
normalmente estamos acostumbrados a ver
las funciones como fx pero aquí lo vamos
a escribir como una ft ya que es muy
común que usemos la transformada de la
plaza para transformar funciones que se
encuentren en el dominio del tiempo y
pasarlas al dominio de la frecuencia
aunque no se preocupen por ello ahorita
no quiero que se confundan
vamos a cerrar nuestra llave aquí para
terminar de escribir esta anotación
va a transformar esta función en otra
función
de hecho déjenme escribir aquí una
notación matemática en que es en lo que
se transforma bueno la forma en la que
yo lo veo es que por ejemplo tenemos una
función que transforma un conjunto de
datos a otro conjunto de números sin
embargo la transformada de la plaza va a
transformar un conjunto de funciones
hacia otro conjunto de funciones por
ejemplo para nuestros propósitos vamos a
definir leal transformada de la plaza de
ft y ésta va a ser la integral impropia
aunque va de bueno no se preocupen y te
lo voy a explicar en un momento la
integral impropia de 0 a infinito
d
elevado a la menos 7 x ft que es lo que
se encuentra adentro de las llaves de
aquí de la transformada
dt y esto puede ser quizás un poco
confuso para ustedes por estas
terminologías pero bueno vamos a
desarrollar esto vamos a ver cuál es la
transformada de la plaza de 1
la transformada de la plaza de uno va a
ser igual ft es igual a 1 vamos a
sustituirlo aquí y esto nos lleva a ver
déjame reescribir esto para que queda un
poquito más claro la integral impropia
de 0 a infinito es igual a la menos ese
porte eso no cambia multiplicada por la
función en la función es 1 así que no lo
voy a escribir pero se entiende
dt
y quizás este infinito les estaba
metiendo un poco de ruido y de hecho
bueno vamos a aclararlo aquí
esto es exactamente lo mismo que si yo
escribo el límite digamos de mi letra a
que tiende al infinito de la integral de
0 a a d
elevado a la menos st dt
y esto lo escribo así para que se
sientan un poquito más cómodos de estar
trabajando con un límite de algo que
tiene el infinito en lugar de tener algo
para evaluar en infinito y ahora sí
vamos a hacer la anti derivada de al
menos 7
para resolver esta integral impropia de
ala menos st dt esto va a ser igual a
menos 1 sobre s x el ala menos st
si no me creen hagan la derivada de este
término y les va a quedar así
de hecho permítanme quitar este signo de
igual aquí lo voy a recorrer un poco a
la izquierda
y
bueno voy a escribir aquí el igual el
límite cuando tiene infinito de hecho lo
escribo así porque es la primera vez que
estamos hablando de integrales impropias
para recordarles que estamos hablando de
límites así que vamos a tomar la anti
derivada y la vamos a evaluar en a y
vamos a restar esta anti derivada
evaluada en cero
así que todo esto es igual al límite
cuando a tiende a infinito bueno vamos a
sustituir a primero aquí si lo hacemos
tenemos menos 1 entre s ya que es la
integral con respecto a t
aquí escribimos el ala menos s por a ya
que eso es lo que estoy haciendo esto
sustituyendo a gente - que pasa cuando
pongo sustituyó a t con el valor de 0 a
pues bueno va a ser voy a multiplicar
ese porte me va a quedar elevado a 0 y
cualquier cosa elevada a la 0 va a ser
igual a 1 así que me queda menos menos
uno en 13
y vamos a bajar un poquito para
continuar escribiendo aquí
esto va a ser igual al límite ya lo puse
en otro color de a cuando tiende a
infinito d
vamos a escribir aquí menos 1 / s
al menos ese por a menos -1 en 13 así
que queda más uno entre s y aquí
cerramos el coche te cuál es el límite
de cuando a tiende a infinito
este término conforme a se hace más
grande se aproxima infinito
y asumimos que ese es mayor que 0 de
hecho vamos a escribirlo aquí ese es
mayor que 0 entonces este término va a
ser menos algo muy grande la eba estará
elevada a la menos algo que tiende al
infinito así que elevado a la menos algo
muy muy grande va a ser un número muy
muy muy chiquito va a tender a cero
cuando a tiende a infinito todo este
término va a tender a cero y por lo
tanto todo este elemento va a ser igual
a cero por lo que nos va a quedar
solamente uno entre ese y este es el
resultado
así que tómense un momento para celebrar
que han resuelto su primera transformada
de la plaza y eventualmente veremos en
futuros vídeos que existe toda una serie
de tablas de transformadas de laplace ya
resueltas pero por el momento vamos a
trabajar con las más básicas
este puede ser nuestro primer registro
en nuestra tabla de transformadas de la
plaza entonces la transformada de la
plaza de 1
va a ser igual a 1 / s recuerden que
aunque este es el 1 estamos evaluando
una función con respecto al tiempo y
ahora la hemos transformado a una
función con respecto a ese y bueno veo
que me queda muy poquito tiempo así que
continuaremos con la transformada de la
plaza en el siguiente vídeo